president Trump technically controls the
Department of Justice onna comes the
Inspector General he seems to restrict
his oversight to Twitter today the
president tweeted this what is taking so
long with the Inspector General support
on crooked Hillary and slippery James
Comey numerous delays hope report is not
being changed and made weaker here are
there are so many horrible things to
tell the public has a right to know
transparency which raises the question
where exactly is that report why haven't
we seen it what could be in it Byron New
York follows all this for the Washington
Examiner and he joins us tonight Byron
what we know about this report well I'm
afraid the president's gonna have to
wait a little longer it appears that
it's going to be delayed again the
Senate Judiciary Committee had scheduled
a hearing for today where they were
supposed to talk about it well that got
delayed until next Monday the 11th now
I'm hearing it might be delayed beyond
that the reasons feet are being dragged
somewhere in this process there is a
hang-up with classified information and
perhaps the most intriguing in the last
at least month or six weeks the
Inspector General has gotten new
information and actually interviewed new
people don't know exactly what that's
about but it shows an investigation
that's been going what do we know about
the content so far all right it's gonna
be probably close to 500 pages and you
can expect a lot of discussion on
several topics expect a lot of
discussion about that Loretta Lynch Bill
Clinton meeting on the tarmac in Arizona
he has looked in the inspector general
has looked into that a lot expect a lot
of discussion on James commis decision
to draft an exoneration memo for Hillary
Clinton long before she had interviewed
Hillary Clinton or at least a dozen
other important witnesses expect a lot
of discussion on whether Comey was
trying to affect the outcome of the
election on October 28th before the
election yes in which he reopened the
investigation the Democrats specifically
wanted the Inspector General to look in
to that look into discussion about when
Andrew McCabe first learned that there
were Hillary Clinton emails on Anthony
Weiner's laptop remember that that was
the reason that that Comey reopened the
investigation but what we found out was
that McCabe knew about it much earlier
in October did he drag his feet if so
why was that just a couple of more
things look for discussion
call me z' long statement on July 5th
and 2016 saying that Hillary Clinton
would not be charged that was yet the
way these decisions are usually
announced so there's gonna be an
investigation of that look into why
Loretta Lynch did not appoint a special
counsel to look into this and why Andrew
McCabe took so long to recuse himself
remember his wife had got worse a huge
Clinton related contribution last thing
the thing we've heard the most about
which is McCabe versus Comey on this
leaking thing mccabe says well you told
me it was okay to leak and Comey said
well no I didn't we may not get a whole
lot more on that simply because we've
already gotten a lot through the Office
of Professional Responsibility federal
agents in the course of an investigation
into himself that would be for civilians
of felony is that a felony in his case
will he be charged well we don't know
there has been a criminal referral to
the Justice Department to look into this
and by the way it has now been reported
McCabe was invited to testify at this
hearing Judiciary Committee hearing
whenever it is and he has asked for
immunity in exchange for his testimony
if he doesn't get it he would have to
take the Fifth Amendment so unlikely to
see him say anything to them but clearly
he is concerned about criminal exposure
from whatever is in this report 500
pages it's a long read wait biron new
york i think one of the most credible
sources of information on this thank you
thank you